on retrouve avec plaisir le ministre des
finances eric girard bonsoir bonsoir
avec les élus excellent est ce que vous
aviez le choix d' harmoniser dans le
fond à monsieur girard ou de ne pas
harmoniser les mesures fédérales compte
tenu de l'importance par exemple du cil
iab nous avons toujours le choix mais
c'est certain que ne pas harmoniser
aurait mis les citoyens québécois dans
une position inéquitable par rapport aux
autres citoyens canadiens et je pense
que c'est des mesures qui favorisent
l'accès à une première habitation way et
le syli ap il sera en vigueur en 2023 le
marché se tempère présentement c'est
donc le bon moment on a fait les
analyses au niveau des morts et on a un
grand monsieur gérard mais c'est à dire
que il faut être clair le marché a été
extrêmement fort et c'est vraiment au
niveau de l'offre qu'il faut travailler
leur éliminant chantiers sont en hausse
de 50% par rapport à ce que nous avions
la moyenne des dix dernières années on a
des programmes pour les logements
sociaux des logements abordables des
suppléments au loyer l'eau lorsqu'on
stimule secteur de la demande c'est
certain qu'on a un impact sur l'ensemble
de la demande alors on se concentre
uniquement sur les premières habitations
et c'est
programme là qui est approprié
maintenant que le marché se tempère oui
ça tempère un peu mais on est encore je
pense en surchauffe immobilière
vous ne trouvez pas est ce que le célia
vient pas alimenter davantage cette
surchauffe le scellier va définitivement
supporter la demande pour une première
habitation mais c'est aussi ce que les
citoyens nous demandent les citoyens
nous disent nous voulons accéder
à la propriété et donc
on est au service des citoyens on a fait
tout ce qu'on peut au niveau de l'offre
aussi au niveau de la microstructure du
marché je rappelle qu'à partir de demain
il sera interdit pour un courtier de
faire de la double représentation
les courtiers acheteurs devront
travailler dans l'intérêt des acheteurs
alors on a posé plusieurs gestes et leur
fallait prendre une décision le
gouvernement fédéral à vendre a aussi
ses intentions le 7 avril 2022 et on
nous annonce t on sans moniz est ce que
vous auriez pu aller plus loin sur la
taxe sur les flip immobilier par exemple
les flip immobilier lire vente
précipitée qui se font à l'intérieur de
12 mois est ce que c'est vraiment
suffisant et en a qui vont dire je vais
attendre treize mois ferme on flippe
immobilier maîtresses moi et je vais les
revendre finalement ben en fait lorsque
je regarde les revenus qui sont
anticipés de cette mesure ce n'est
définitivement pas le facteur qui
stimule le marché ce qui s'est passé
c'est que nous avons eu une pandémie et
que les gens voulaient plus d espace
pour travailler pour étudier pour vivre
les gens ont moins voyagé les taux
d'intérêt étaient 1 0% et sa salle a
amené une demande extrêmement forte
l'iffhs lépine mobilier c'est une infime
partie de ça et il nous attendons moins
de 2 millions de revenus par année de
cette mesure sur l'inflation vous étiez
à 4 7% dans le budget vous êtes à
combien le dans votre estimation
aujourd'hui sur 2022 ça change quoi pour
vous d'avoir une inflation plus élevée
mais d'abord
l'estimé la révision de l'estimé de
l'inflation pour 2022 du gouvernement du
québec ça va venir dans le rapport pré
électorale en vertu de loi nous devons
transmettre
ouvrira la vérificatrice générale à la
fin juin un nouveau cadre financier de
nouvelles hypothèses économiques ok le
la vérificatrice générale va faire son
travail ce sera publié divulgué à
l'ensemble des populations au début mai
mais lorsqu'on regarde les observations
là on a des données jusqu'au mois
d'avril on a eu 6 8% au mois d'avril et
la banque du canada a déjà dit que mais
serait plus élevé car avril donc le
notre prévision de 4 points 7 % elle est
trop basse je l'admets et la moyenne
annuelle bien que il nous reste subite
observations à connaître
risque d'avoir signer 6% est ce que
c'est bon pour le gouvernement ça est-ce
que c'est plus de revenus parce qu'on
voit votre déficit fondent à vue d'oeil
aussi là dans l'ensemble les revenus
sont fonction du pib nominal alors oui
les revenus sont plus élevés lorsqu'il y
a plus des classiques et donc ça dégage
la marge de manoeuvre pour le chèque
dont a parlé le premier ministre legault
récemment nouveau chaque que vous allez
annoncer sur lequel vous travaillez
présentement en fait tous les partis
travaillent
ont des réflexions sur ce qu'ils vont
présenter aux électeurs durant
l'élection on a une élection le 3
octobre nous nous avons compensé pour
vous savez le régime fiscal est indexé
cette année de deux point 6% nous avons
compensé pour un panier de consommation
de base de 25 mille dollars la
différence entre l'inflation anticipée 4
points 7 % et l'indexation du régime
fiscal donc une compensation de 2 % sur
un panier de 25000 dollars 500 dollars
si l'inflation est plus élevée que 4
points 7 % ce que je viens de vous
prévenir il serait approprié de faire un
ajustement suprême de quelques centaines
de dollars mais en fonction des données
de l'inflation que nous aurons dans les
prochains mois
beaucoup de vos collègues parlementaires
c'est la fin de la session monsieur
girard puis bon c'est quasiment le début
de la campagne électorale il ya beaucoup
de collègues qui s'en vont un collecteur
de mineurs qui ont fait leurs adieux et
vous vous restez vous vous représentez
n'est ce pas oui c'est vraiment un
honneur d'être le fiduciaire des
finances publiques et puis ça n'a pas
été facile nous avons eu la pire
récession depuis
et la deuxième guerre mondiale et
mon premier était il ya eu une fuite de
données
de renseignement dans l'industrie
financière importante
c'est il reste du travail à faire on
veut amener le québec un autre niveau
que le pib potentiel du québec s'élève
d'un point 5% à 2% on va fermer l'écart
de richesse avec l'ontario il reste du
travail à faire ça me fait plaisir de me
représente est votre premier ministre
parle beaucoup de fierté c'est ainsi
vous vous êtes de quoi êtes vous le plus
fier comme ministre des finances depuis
quatre ans mais je pense que le québec a
montré sa résilience c'est à dire que
l'économie du québec ont subi un choc
on a eu une fermeture pendant six
semaines de près de 40% de l'économie
les finances publiques on nous sommes
passés d'une situation de surplus
budgétaires un déficit est estimé de 15
milliards de dollars en 36 heures et la
situation aussi les entreprises se sont
adaptées lesquels les québécois se sont
adaptés je pense que notre résilience
collective tant l'économique les
finances publiques on peut être fier
merci monsieur girard c'est un plaisir
merci beaucoup bon et et puis je vous
dis de toute bonne campagne merci
beaucoup pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit